how do you feel about needles as the
world competes to develop a coronavirus
vaccine
there are people in southern africa who
want to get involved
in the city of johannesburg two
large-scale
vaccine trials are underway
and a third will start in a couple of
weeks
and there are thousands here who are
willing to participate
you're having second thoughts
do you think this vaccine could work
think so and i hope so it works because
this disease i can't even
this feeling can be described
in a clinic in the township of soweto
health staff administer
the second dose of a new vaccine
developed by oxford university
and this is an excellent place to test
it
the virus has run rampant in south
africa
with the number of infections hurtling
past six hundred thousand
there are a lot of people are dying out
there just so if we find the right thing
didn't do this buffy up in the lab
we found the trial organizer professor
shabir mahdi
and he's got his own list of demands if
he can show these vaccines work in
africa the pharmaceutical companies will
have to distribute them in africa
as well what we need to understand is
that there's no
rush on a part of pharmaceutical
companies to come and do vaccine studies
in africa none at all the only reason is
being done in south africa is because i
went
out to convince people that you need to
do the studies now
in south africa on the african continent
and we can't wait
for the studies to be done after the
pandemic has passed
it may take years or even a generation
he says
to develop effective covet vaccines but
he thinks everyone should get the
benefit it's tight
it's cramped it's very busy they're
doing 18-hour shifts in the lab
with a new vaccine from the united
states also being trialed
but here's the thing will people take it
if it works
one trial participant warned us her
friends and neighbors
would never take a vaccine for covid 19.
to be honest especially uh black people
be taking this lightly
because we have this mindset that this
illness is only
taking white people rich people and
stuff but
it's like they're trying to say that
this disease can
see it can feel like that you have money
and then it comes attacking
the coronavirus selects its prey
it's one of a number of myths and
misconceptions that
south african researchers are now
encountering
and their work may be as important as
the scientists
in the lab we join one team in soweto
um what do you think about that the
vaccine for me is like
it's like they're here in south africa's
like they're going to kill black people
why do you say that where does it come
from
okay okay take the vaccine
never no no no no no no no you wouldn't
die
oh yeah yeah you never know because like
to build herd immunity the majority need
to vaccinate
but these residents won't be easy to
convince
they don't trust it because they feel
that it's not it's not
real you know whoever invented the
vaccine or wherever it originates from
they are bringing it here to kill
people so they believe there are things
that have been done or that are put in
that vaccine
to reduce the number of population in
africa
scientists are fighting africa's corner
in an attempt to secure an effective
vaccine
but they need to make the case on the
streets for doubt
and suspicion are festering john sparks
sky news johannesburg